and the rhetoric right so when you see
that and then
let's say it was conversely you know blm
black lives matter or whatever
and then then you see the title says
thugs degenerate yeah exactly right
yeah then you see this you see patriots
and americans so it's like
how do you yeah sure yeah and i think
that's like the part that causes like
that huge divide it's
you know it's media is personally
responsible for that too it's oh yeah
how they titled this
yeah it's like why are these people also
not thugs and degenerates absolutely
absolutely it's because it's easy in
five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast
uh nick is right now in hawaii dude
just living it up and [ __ ] dude
i don't trust that guy you and nick are
the only ones in the group that haven't
gotten
it yet i don't yeah right i don't think
so yeah thank you
pat bart uh
akko has it i don't think akko hasn't i
think aqua has the cure dude that's why
yeah goes taking like three billion
tests too and he like posts
every time he gets a test he's like 10
and now
i've been trying to stay extra safe like
after when we had the covet scare like
i've kind of just been
low-key you know it only takes one
[ __ ] person it's literally
one person there's always somebody you
trust too bart wuhan quan
what's weird is it how it hits certain
people but not other right trust me
when you so when pat got it i thought we
were all gonna have it i was like oh i
[ __ ] got it because i sparred with
pat
you know we all that [ __ ] like that and
i didn't get it and i was like how the
[ __ ] did i not get it
like it's so weird it's interesting
we're um i'm thankful that we didn't get
it i'll read a bunch of articles
apparently
um yeah the the the time that you can
get it the most is when somebody is very
symptomatic yeah so you weren't
symptomatic yet
no so like we made our chances that's
true
he literally sucked me in my retina so i
was like i for sure have it i remember
your glove touching my eyes and it went
back in
i'm like oh man i got this [ __ ] for sure
but yeah but ever since then i've just
kind of been just chilling
at home playing video games which kind
of and i haven't been working out which
kind of sucks but
i think kind of now like all scaredy
[ __ ] they have the new strand from
the the england one or whatever yeah the
uk it's like 70
months what 70 70
more likely to get it yeah contagious
it's more contagious
and something like it affects kids now
too that's like the thing now too
everyone was like yeah because they had
it in the uk and i think like in the
east coast and then they found some in
colorado and then they have one case
here in california that they found
which is good i don't know how they know
which ones which i know right there bro
california wild right now too bro it's
like people just can't
like wear masks they just can't they
just can't follow this [ __ ] it's like
bruh i want to live normal again and
like i understand people get mad they
don't want to wear these masks and [ __ ]
but you know if we just would have
listened in the beginning we'd probably
be in a better spot right about to get
that vaccine though
we're just talking about that outside
this one
all right so here's my thing about the
vaccine with the vaccine i was literally
because pat the first thing me and pat
talked about this right when i saw him
he's like getting at the vaccine
so i understand in the sense of people
that are like oh i'm not getting the
vaccine
i only in the sense of i don't want to
be i don't want to take it first
you know what i'm saying yeah absolutely
like i'd rather like let people take it
because i haven't gotten sick right and
i stay
pretty safe like i feel like i do a
pretty good job i don't do anything
uh david gave me a bunch of n95 masks i
got those
my clients just gave me a [ __ ] ton today
so i only wear those now
and so like i'm trying to stay super st
super safe
but like i want you know if that [ __ ]
like turned you into like a mutant and
[ __ ] i
try to take it first it's been pretty
i mean every vaccine has their side
effects right
but i think it's pretty tried and true
where they go through enough clinical
trials well
i'll trust it enough right yeah that's
what i heard i heard that there was over
like four hundred thousand
people were saying some funny [ __ ] where
they're like i guess like somebody put
up an article that a nurse took the
vaccine
right yeah and she and then and then she
got coveted and i'm like well
there's two stages of it yeah right you
didn't get the full vaccine
so you caught covered which vaccines
don't prevent you from
getting the thing 100 it just allows you
to find it off a lot better than other
people
right so i think people don't understand
what vaccines are for so it's like when
you get the flu every time i get the flu
shot i'm sick for like two days
yeah you know and so people have been
getting it they're like i don't feel
good like you get that with the flu shot
too like yeah because aren't they like
putting it they're actually putting the
screens right yeah and that's why i saw
that too and then i saw a bunch of
comments on it they're like well yeah
because
it's a two-part thing he only took the
first one yeah so of course
if you take one you can still get it
yeah but this one there's two vaccines
and one of them apparently isn't the the
diseases in it it's like a protein from
the disease
it like teaches your body how to like
fight against the particular protein i
don't know this is way above my [ __ ]
head yeah
that's what someone said to me like that
and trying to
try to sound smart
but uh my buddy is a firefighter too one
of his
co-workers took the first one and got
coveted in between the second one you
need both you need
to [ __ ] be effective but to your
logic it's like yeah like [ __ ]
hold out on ps5s and xbox
yeah you know the new xbox is new ps5
people like i'ma wait a little bit
yeah the first ones are always a little
defunct exactly
called nurses and doctors are already
getting it now yeah see they're getting
it away and if
i'm not scared to take it but i'm just
like supports trump i have time
i should be over there right now in that
building he's got the camera
ready to arrive no uh you look scared
though bro
i might say if i don't need to take it
please
bruh no straight up like i never i
probably should but i never get the flu
shots
i never do
we good for like another like two three
months we finally like i kind of wish i
would have got it from one of you guys
already so i could be
like it sucks it was like
i don't want to get it because i have i
see clients who are old and
yeah all that type of [ __ ] so like i
don't want to get it but like also i'm
like [ __ ] i wish
i can just if i knew like i wasn't gonna
get [ __ ] up like real bad i wish i
could just get it and get it over with
it's not a very pleasant thing though i
tell you that
just because like number one there's no
way to make sure that your headache
subsides
like usually if i have the flu or
whatever i take tylenol i could feel my
fever drop or whatever and then my
headache kind of goes away this [ __ ]
none of that stuff works
yeah writing it out damn so nyquil or
nothing even worked for you
no i was just like well i didn't have
the i had fever for like a day
okay but then i had this crazy it felt
like my nose cavity was completely
cleared out through my brain
like so every time i breathe in if it
smelled like i was breathing in like
tiger balm did it occur
too like when yeah so my sinus area all
the way through here was hurting for
like
three days so i was my brain felt like
it was frying
yeah so those first three days like i
mean i was still making jokes that's
who i am
and then when the lower back pain
started happening the hip pain started
happening bad [ __ ] yeah which sucked
because i was like hey as long
i'm gonna start shadow boxing i couldn't
even do that dude yeah
see i don't even think i know because my
lower back always hurt you know what i'm
saying
no but i remember like a lot like
mentally right like
it shows how like strong like your mind
can be on you sometimes like when we had
the first one
like i was home and literally i felt i
started
feeling like [ __ ] sick i was like but
i wasn't i didn't feel sick
all right let me tell you something
after after you had kobe this
[ __ ] was tripping out man really
this dude this dude was tripping the
[ __ ] out he goes no i got this i can
feel it
i got tested three times and i was
negative each time but the last test
like literally was weird it was like
right when i got the last test
and it was like negative like it felt
like a light switch like all of a sudden
i felt like
hundred percent yeah yeah i was like
all right i'm good then actually that
actually probably was the best part
about for me
getting it was the relief of like all
right the little tingle in my throat
like i used to be like you too where i
was like [ __ ] i got it everyone i know
is going to die i just killed my mom
i don't think crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah but
now the [ __ ] only lasts like
they think three months right the
antibodies or they don't know yeah it's
about three months i think so and then
uh i'm for sure gonna get the vaccine
just because i know what kobe felt like
yeah i mean honestly like straight up if
it's because it's not available just to
go get right now is it no
it'll probably be like summer yeah so
like when it's available i mean i'll
take it you know my mom's in like health
care worker
i mean i might take it i mean but i'm
probably not going to take it so nervous
right yeah
yeah i've done yourself i'll take it
i'll take it but no but the antibody
shit's true because my brother tested
for covid and the antibodies a while
back and he had he was positive for the
antibodies
and then he just told me i talked to him
when was it like a month ago he said he
got retested
and he didn't have the antibodies
anymore oh really it was about three
months
in between and yeah he didn't have
antibodies anymore so he could
not possibly re-get it yeah so it's so
my buddy
one of my buddies he's an active friend
of mine he had coveted and i didn't know
and so he messaged me on
uh on instagram he was like hey how are
you doing are you okay i was like i mean
i'm good man like
you know i fought it off because i had
it four months ago i was like oh [ __ ]
how are you doing now he goes honestly
i'm i'm still [ __ ]
like wow one of the things that i
noticed that i still have now is my
energy's not the same
oh really so i take naps now like i
never take naps like
it's it's weird like i get sleepy and i
also it's hard for me to wake up now
so i usually just wake up at like 9 a.m
no matter what time i sleep today i woke
up at 12
i got kind of smashed yesterday that
might be a little happy
with it but never mind that no let's cut
that
but like my energy levels aren't the
same so i get tired a lot faster
um which i've been trying to like kind
of fight through it but it's kind of
weird
how sleepy i get you know what i think
plays a part in that as well too
is probably us not training as much as
we used to well for sure
you know you know but my other buddy the
biggest thing that he has memory loss
i know two people who had memory loss
and he doesn't remember [ __ ] from like
three months ago and another buddy of
mine doesn't remember [ __ ] for like
like four or five months
things are all fuzzy so if you like wow
and i started cracking up well he didn't
find this funny but i was like
i was like what if you lost your memory
from like four years back
and then i tell you like trump's
president right now this goes like nah
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] with me i'm like
not for real bro
like trump's president but people i
guess like it's where like you don't
really think about
what that makes somebody feel like
because it's all a joke until you get it
yeah right right because for me i mean i
took it i wore the mask i socially
distanced except for one time i went to
a party
you know i got [ __ ] up with that at
least you got to see mike tyson back in
action baby
i know which was [ __ ] dope that was
dope as [ __ ]
no that that is scary like i don't want
to get it and it just sucks because
you gonna get it just always stressing
about it all right i got it right now
dude
i'm like [ __ ] all right yeah we got
pellegrino though so we good
let's go kill the vitamins and the
killer greens baby
did you see the uh [ __ ] uh jake paul
is now calling out
all these ufc fighters yeah oh really
it's the more it's more honestly well he
called out so his management or whatever
reached out to
uh ben askren and i also reached out to
mike bisbee
oh i heard about it i thought they were
going to box i heard bisping and him
were going to like
weren't they working out there i heard
mike bisman was like i'll do it let's
[ __ ] do it [ __ ] his ass
i know even with one eye he'll [ __ ] his
ass up with one eye he [ __ ] up some of
the best fighters in the world
yeah it's like i wish but you know
they're gonna
those guys are smart in that sense where
they're gonna do these fights that are
just gonna make them money
and like they have a a at least a chance
to win right now
he could probably yeah if it's just
boxing but here even though
we had talked about about this before
like even with aspirin i'm like
but ascrine is an actual fighter he's a
fighter
right so like i don't even think jake
paul just goes in there and just beats
him up because
he's been hit and also he's finally
gonna box somebody his size
they're the same size oh really because
uh i think he's six one
and asked for a six one okay so you know
he fought little little [ __ ] nate
robinson
yeah you know that's never boxed a day
in his life
and he's five foot eight you know it's
like come on bro i had some intel on
that too so because someone came into
the shop
and uh after it was like a day after the
fight happened and
i was kind of like low-key kind of
talking [ __ ] about not about nate but
like about
why the [ __ ] you would even do it and
she started kind of looking weird
and i was like oh why did you did you
watch it she's like
yeah i actually work for nate oh [ __ ] i
was like really she's like yeah i was
like
i'm just being real with you like he
should have not done this
like i was like how long did he train
like how long did he actually train for
this fight she's like
i don't know it seemed like maybe only
like three months i'm like that's
that's the issue yeah right i'm like
jake paul at least i'm even though he's
fighting
youtubers that don't know how to fight
and [ __ ] like that at least he's been
training for over a year
like two years two years ago and he's
fine already so he kind of knows that
feeling already
i'm like he has and then i heard that he
never even sparred in his camp
nate robinson that's remember hilarious
never even sparked so like what do you
expect it's gonna happen yeah right
that's right you actually did pretty
good jesus yeah
he actually didn't do it i remember i
remember telling someone one of my
friends i'm like they're like how do you
think the fight's gonna go i'm like nate
robinson's gonna run in and just keep
grabbing him
yeah he doesn't he's never done this
before that's exactly what's gonna
happen that's exactly what happened then
he got caught well this is the weird
thing too
like people are asking i have no
interest to see
uh jake jake paul fight again like i've
seen it once and i'm like i'm good
yeah you know like i don't care like the
main reason why i wanted to watch it was
because of
mike tyson yeah the only reason that was
the [ __ ] bro mike tyson looked [ __ ]
fantastic
did you see a couple of shots he pulled
back he was going to go to the door yeah
stop i was like
yeah yeah you could have killed him
yeah i was telling people that too i'm
like it's like because
it was supposed to be an exhibition
there's not supposed to be any winner
there wasn't supposed to be any
knockouts right
and they got so much [ __ ] for it and so
they're like okay
there will be a winner uh all this type
of [ __ ] right but
i'm like you know you knew their plan
because they had two belts made already
yeah so of course no one was gonna win
if it went to decision of course it was
gonna be a draw
so no one wins it was already evident
when they were like interviewing mike
tyson and roy jones jr and they go so
mike what do you think about the split
this is
i like it yeah it is great
it's great i'm like he didn't even
finish the question bro
it's perfect that's exactly what i
expect no i didn't plan it never mind
this is what was in the car i mean this
is uh i'm just like yeah it was
it was cool though to see he did look
good he looked good the slipping like
the wheat like he was like
on point with the slips and the body
shots he landed were drastic as [ __ ]
he won clearly yeah clearly yeah you're
right he held back he could have knocked
him out but that's like the evolution of
mike tyson which is kind of dope to see
like in his younger days he would have
[ __ ]
bit his [ __ ] face off now he's like
taking it easy you can tell to the body
he was kind of giving it to him maybe
like 90
but the head you could tell my oh my god
you could tell you're not throwing that
[ __ ] with
your feelings now dude which is so weird
this little straight up said he goes why
are you
why is nobody worried about me
what nobody worried about i yeah i've
been boxing
15
he was literally upset that nobody was
worried about him like mike tyson is a
different man
he's way different bro but i mean no one
was worried about him because he like
clearly won
this podcast is brought to you by better
help is there something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
well guess what my friends betterhelp
will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional
therapist listen i have been doing
online counseling for quite a while now
and it's something that is a part of my
daily because i do realize
that mental health is something that i
need to exercise constantly just like i
do with my physical health
you know a lot of the times we ignore
the stuff that we have inside our head
because we feel like it's either a sign
of weakness or that's how i felt anyways
but when i reached out for help and i
had the counseling that i needed that i
wanted during the time that i needed
especially that i could do it at the
comfort of my home
it just made it a lot easier more
accessible betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today
visit their website and you can read
their testimonies and they're
posted daily about people who love it so
listen visit betterhelp.com
genius that's better help and join over
1 million people who have taken charge
of their mental health with the help of
an experienced professional
and in fact so many people have been
using better health they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
so
special offer for my genius brain
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
slash genius that's betterhelp.com
genius today yeah yeah i feel like he
clearly won and i figured
like watching him hit mitts i'm like oh
he's still happy you know what the weird
thing was like roy jones's
uh tactic for fighting or boxing mike
tyson was that he
was going to wear him out but roy jones
was way more tired than michael
oh yeah mike didn't look exhausted at
all at all so his plan went out the
[ __ ] windows like yo mike's
conditioning is better
and the body shots i mean the body shots
definitely added up for sure
a couple mike tyson body shots will
deplete your [ __ ] gadget
you could tell too cause like even i
know i saw an interview with mike tyson
and he was like
it's like that championship mentality
right he was like yeah my wife called me
fat
so i started working out again so i went
on the couch that's all it takes what
the [ __ ] that's it yeah he's like so i
went on the treadmill in it i started
with 20 minutes he's like
and then the next day that 20 minutes
turned into two hours
and i just went two hours and gonna suck
this dick oh is that what you're gonna
say to me
the next day it was one dick then it was
20 dicks then it was 30.
next thing you know [ __ ]
my brother literally had a shirt and we
didn't know what it meant right we had
no idea what it meant but he bought a
shirt online off this website
and it was it said bukaki tsunami oh
yeah and it was a it was a p
it was like some band i forget the band
i don't know if that's the band name
but it was literally a bunch of people
running like if they're running from
like a big-ass monster and it was just a
bunch of like white [ __ ] flying
but we had no idea what it was this fool
used to wear to school and then one day
he got dress coded we're like what
he's like what's the problem here that
is semen
though and then he also had a cannibal
corp shirt and basically it was like a
zombie like the
top half of a zombie and like the rest
of his like guts and [ __ ] just hanging
out
and just like at the end of the guts was
just his big ass balls and weird
oh my god dude what are you doing what
does it take for him to get caught for
that [ __ ] uh
that sure i think that sure he got dress
coded immediately and then he also we
all we both got these slayer shirts that
had a big demon head with a pentagram
like
carved in with a knife on the forehead
he wore that one day and got
and got dressed coated and then i got
dress coded once for an iron maiden
shirt
because the back of it said 666 the
number of the beasts because i was like
their big song remember the beast
so i got dress coded for it and i
remember walking down because the
principal came and brought me he's like
hey look
i'm actually an iron maiden fan so it's
kind of cool you're wearing this shirt
he's like but
some people here kind of get offended by
that stuff so i have to
dress i'm also a [ __ ] fan
that's my [ __ ] smell my shirt smell it
you got a black light look at this black
light
splash going cocky this morning
hey yo we good
have you ever got suspended yeah i got
suspended i got expelled in elementary
school
elementary yeah because i stabbed the
kid for the pencil pencil
i got suspended a month into my new
elementary school
and then i got suspended at junior high
for a couple of weeks
or fighting a couple times and then high
school i was a lot better about not
fighting in school there you go yeah
that's the trick
outside you know there's no point in
[ __ ] fighting over here and then
getting your ass beat at home
i just was so hot tempered you know i
was like because people used to always
say in high school
just wait till after school i'm like why
wait yeah and now i understand why
yeah let's just do it right here
yeah yeah i would start swinging or
whatever but then for them they're just
like you idiot
we're going to get in trouble now that's
that's probably why they say after
school yeah
that makes sense yeah i never got i just
got kicked out
of high school my senior year you got
kicked out of the whole school yeah
just so many absences i have many
[ __ ] t-shirts
you know i've been cocky on my mind and
[ __ ] i was like no i got
for i was just ditching so much because
i turned 18 the beginning of senior year
so like it was like downhill from there
because i was like [ __ ] this i don't
even i'm like can't you write your own
notes when you're 18 and just be like
you're a parent so i tried i wanted to
get that done
but they were i like i kind of went to
the front office trying to play it off
like oh yeah you know some days i might
have to go to work earlier but it might
be like once
day out of the month they're like okay
well uh
here's the paper your parents still need
to sign this and i was just like [ __ ]
yeah because i knew right when i told my
days i ain't signing that [ __ ] i was
like [ __ ]
but so i just didn't go did you ever
just forge your parents signature
no i honestly i never did i did actually
one time i didn't actually do it though
so my mom forgot to sign a piece of
paper for me it was like some report
card [ __ ] that i was like in trouble or
whatever like that so she had to sign it
but she forgot to sign it so like i
texted her i'm like yo you didn't sign
the paper
that i need she's like all right well
then just do your whatever i say
forge my signature so she did her
signature on a piece of paper and drew
and took a picture of it and sent it to
me and i was trying to practice it and i
could not get it done because i still
have my dad's signature to the [ __ ]
tee
relationships nice dude yeah i can force
the [ __ ] out of it
damn partially because my dad was lazy
as [ __ ] yeah you know it's just like
you're failing anyways just saying
yourself yeah so you have a f no [ __ ]
yeah see my dad's my my mom's signature
is like super
she's like really good at it so it's
super clean so i couldn't
i couldn't do it so i'd have one of my
friends actually like
she practiced it a couple times and then
she signed my paper and my dad's
signature is
weird as [ __ ] it's like it's four
letters for his whole name
oh it's like a bunch of squigglies and
[ __ ] it's like it's it's literally it's
like this long too
i'm like bro just you know d a bro david
acosta that's it i can't
you know so like so every year we do
this like a friendsgiving thanksgiving
thing right
and then we were just kind of this year
we did it through zoom so there's one
friend that always
uh sets it up her name is she's gonna be
so happy that i said her name
she's the weirdest [ __ ] i've ever met
in my life
we were just going through these funny
ass old high school stories that you
don't remember
until you start having a conversation
with somebody yeah so this girl is so
[ __ ] hilarious right
maybe i'll bleep out your name
so this girl was so [ __ ] funny
because she was that one girl in the
group
that habitually had a crutches on
everybody in the group
okay so if she would get denied once she
was like i'm moving on to this
[ __ ] i shot down my everybody it's a
[ __ ] group dude
the funniest thing that i completely
forgot my best friend this dude is so
[ __ ] up but he didn't know that this
was gonna happen because so
she didn't have a date for prom so there
was this other girl
one of our friends within the group was
like oh hey gabo
why don't you take out this girl right
this full legit says he goes ugh what
the [ __ ] hell no
he says that and she's standing right
behind him it's the funniest [ __ ]
thing ever oh my god
bro that's terrible i was like bro why
would you do that he goes i didn't
[ __ ] know she was right behind me
ew
you guys would be cute together and the
girl says eel
she was so strong like during the time
that she had a crush on me
she [ __ ] she was like one of those
girls i like the rough house of [ __ ]
this [ __ ] grab my backpack and pour it
in half off my back
passing this out you're dating me
i had no backpack at all my books fell
out i turned around i'm like yo what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you why would you do
that yeah
and she's just so awkwardly laughing and
she just tore my gap
backpack and you know gap was a [ __ ]
like
you want to [ __ ] but bro
when i was in school it was jan sport oh
jessica
still popping dude that's the backpack
though that's the one that was the only
one
that's the one that came out yeah that
wacko that's
all people's stuff just papers and i
know [ __ ] dude my binder just papers
that was so bad bro literally i my
backpack
straight up like you could do this to it
like i had nothing in it i put like oh
believe
two pieces of paper like some pencils
and then
mainly what i would do because there was
a shirt okay right right next to
school i would go there and buy like
snacks for the day and just put it in my
backpack
there's one guy that we were talking
about in the group that cracked me up
and it goes on the topic of like you you
i'm pretty sure people have met people
like this before but they're like
habitual liars
like they don't number one they don't
know either know how to lie
or they go too far with their lives it's
so just
obviously a [ __ ] lie so this is a guy
that moved from some other [ __ ] state
into our school right he became best
friends with this other kid
who's also a habitual liar so these two
just [ __ ] each other all the time
but i remember the funniest lie that he
ever did and it was because
somebody was talking about some like
hood gang [ __ ] right
and none of us are you know my friends
in the high school were none of us like
thugs we were just enamored by whatever
this guy was talking about yeah
and this fool had the funniest voice too
he had like a kermit the frog voice
and he just kind of came he goes he goes
yeah i know what that's like he's
alright yeah no
he's like i know that's like you know
it's like i'm like
like really dude like you do he goes
yeah man i had all these friends and uh
they are you know they were killed in
new york you know
and out of nowhere i cannot make this up
he just goes
[ __ ] new york gangs
stop and look at him like the [ __ ] are
you doing
[ __ ] new york games
dead silent we all just like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
he oversold it yeah wow just came in
real casual he's like shaking at the sky
yeah yeah the camera pans in
his knees and [ __ ] look at somebody like
that i'm like
if you're going to be a habitual liar
why don't you practice your lies
or something you know how come he
couldn't just do it suddenly he's like
yeah like i had a couple of homies who
died out in new york it was pretty sad
yeah we'll say yeah i know what this is
like [ __ ] new york guys
[ __ ] bro wow dude but i guess if you're
gonna lie like that you gotta go hard
you know what i mean
it doesn't feel good do it the chill way
you know you gotta go with the theatrics
the shakespeare the look up in the
in the [ __ ] sky camera like that's
how you gotta go i'm just staring at the
sky you're like
everything i was like i just pictured it
in this room practicing it all day i
know
what i mean and then mary's like all
right no don't do it that way dude i
know the school's ghetto and now
somebody's gonna ask me about big games
i gotta get this
he was such an odd [ __ ] character and
he was doing a lot of stuff that you
when you
when you don't know where somebody's
from you could technically make up any
story that you want
yeah because how are you gonna fact
check you yeah you're new it's [ __ ]
impossible especially back in there we
didn't have twitter and all this other
stuff
right so he would just say these
fragrant [ __ ] lies all the time about
how many people he would be he's like a
really sweet dude yeah but it's like
dog no yeah
[ __ ] his skin's all falling off and you
know well
i've met a couple people like that but
like the worst one i remember this guy
was talking to us at the gym
he was all talking about how how uh he
turned down an offer from the raiders
right so this is the guy like literally
anything that would come up
oh yeah i used to do that oh yeah i used
to do that oh yeah i used to work for
that
like we were getting a sign put up oh
yeah yeah i used to put up signs
like [ __ ]
best friends with them oh that's my
that's my good homie that's my good
homie it's just like all right
but like he was talking to us once and
we were talking about football
right and about how like if you got an
offer for a football team
even if you weren't gonna play that you
would still take it because it'd be dumb
for you not to
i turned it down oh we all just look at
him like
what what he's like yeah [ __ ] the
raiders offered me they were like hey we
want to pay you like
i think he said like a million something
bucks he's like we want to pay you a
million bucks but you're gonna have to
be second string he's like so
man i said [ __ ] that if i ain't playing
i ain't being on the team
we're like bro i just walked away i
could not stand this [ __ ]
that was the funniest thing i've ever
heard of my life you turned down
so one of the most dangerous sports in
the world you don't even have to play
but hey you're going to get millions of
dollars nah
nah i'm good bro
one of my homies was so good at calling
people out for their [ __ ] he would
do this [ __ ] that that i picked up on
later on
is like habitual liars they like the
attention right so
whatever it is like that that one up
thing is is pretty evident of it
if it's pretty ridiculous obviously if
you're homies you're going to share
stories and that's that's fine
but what this fool would do which was
genius is that when these fools would go
on like
like let's say it was that guy right he
was [ __ ] new york gangs guys he would
start telling a story right
and then he would just say a made-up
story that's ridiculous and he will wait
for him to one-up it
and so he would just keep doing over and
over and over and then he'll stew it was
like hey
that's like last time when we were at
that store right and people were
squaring up on week
we said what's up to him he was like
yeah we did he goes no he did it [ __ ]
it didn't happen
gassed him up for like 10 minutes and
then just roast these people towards the
end like you're
a [ __ ] dummy yeah because they they
don't even know they get caught up and
they just start
rolling into this this [ __ ] this
donut hole of disaster
i don't care how you can live like that
like just perpet like just constantly
telling [ __ ] lies
yeah well they they lie so much that
they just believe
they're like they just leave a point
just like someone i know in the [ __ ]
white house bro
but like yeah like they just [ __ ]
keep lying and lying lying and just make
people believe them
and make themselves believe you know
somebody that that we know i'm gonna
tell you guys after the podcast
the buffalo choice real quick oh yeah
get that get that drink yeah get that
drink cause i'll be sipping on that
come on but he said he said like he told
us the funniest story about somebody
that he knew
and this dude so when he told me about
him originally
it already sounded really far-fetched
right just because he reminded me of
somebody that i met in
uc riverside that was also a habitual
liar so this guy
was extreme with his lies right so he
would tell him kind of stuff and this is
our buddy and you know him too would
regurgitate the stories to me and it
just sounded so outlandish
he goes like he's like tell him he goes
yo so this dude i know
like um he was he used to be a part of
the cia
and i off uh right off the jump i'm like
this sounds ridiculous
david already has that face like okay so
who is this guy right he goes yes so he
says so we were
we were driving right and then he just
looks at the building and he goes
i know where the exits are what the [ __ ]
is jason bourne like some jason bourne
[ __ ] yeah he goes yeah i already know
where the exits are and then he would
turn around the corner
and then the reason why he believed them
is because they would drive by the
building and on the side there was an
exit door he go see
yeah he would call it out there's an
exit door right there yeah
buildings have doors bro
he knew there was a door he must be part
of the cia
yeah and so they started piecing stuff
together is when they took him to a
shooting range
and so he was talking about you know
he's a secret cia agent how fast he
could draw his gun how he would kill the
murder targets on it
right so they're like oh let's take this
fool to a shooting range because they
were hyped up to see what he could do
tell me why this fool missed all the
targets
something's wrong with the gun
like this what's wrong with this all
right let me let me take it out okay
[ __ ] pistol in his mouth he starts
doing weird shitties like this he's like
they're like you're not supposed to hold
on uh yeah the inside uh
particular is awesome how many minutes
does it take for me to spawn back
bro how great would it have been if some
[ __ ] actually cracked off and that dude
just got
he's like i got it guys get shot in the
chest and there's a moment to be like he
didn't know [ __ ] and then you get shot
you know anything like the last thing
you [ __ ] think
it is [ __ ] crazy that's bananas i
don't understand that why would he go to
the shooting race
i know right
one of my clients is like that because
my clients one of my clients is super
smart right and i tell you guys about
this guy all the time it's a guy that's
older that i see in simi valley right
but this guy has the craziest stories
right so like one i'll tell you one
story so he was part of
the army like the us army and stuff like
that right but he wasn't brought
in to be part of uh like battle and that
type of [ __ ] he was brought in for intel
intelligence right and like this is the
level smart he is when he was in high
school a senior in high school
uh they his school got in contact with
nasa because nasa had made public about
some math problem they couldn't figure
out right
so they contact nasa and say we have
someone that can figure out your problem
and they said okay so they brought it to
him my client uh
figured out the math problem for them
right so that's how smart this guy was
right he's super smart
you know he built a whole internet
security software that a lot of stuff
uses and stuff
but so he goes to the army and it's
there's a project called the phoenix
project and there's movies about this
and
you can read it up and all that type of
[ __ ] right uh but
he was part of the army but he was part
of like where you know he had to go do
all the trainings for shooting and that
type of [ __ ]
because of stuff that he might have had
to be in he had to know how to shoot
you know shoot snipers and all that type
of stuff but when they got him into the
army and they told him hey we want to be
part of this project called the phoenix
project
and so what they intel them on was like
oh basically we just need you to help
set up missions for us that we can help
capture
terrorists right and they said we wanted
to be super sneaky
where you go you let us know what to do
what times and all this type of stuff
and we'll capture these people
he's like so i said okay you know yes he
said he went to go in their first
meeting their very first meeting they
said
let us know basically like where we need
a bomb
he's like what are you talking about
he's like well where should we just bomb
he's like well that's gonna kill a bunch
of people
he's like why would we bomb that i can
tell you how to go well it's faster if
we do it this way
so with that information he said i'm not
doing this i'm not going to help you
guys out
which caused like a huge you know issue
in there because you're telling these
people that
you're not going to help him out so they
actually kicked him out of the army
and he was telling me he's like oh it
was like a movie when i got home like
literally on the plane ride home i wrote
about the whole entire phoenix project
what it was what they said it was but
what it actually was going to be
la i wrote it and when i got off the
plane the first thing i did was mail it
out to newspapers
he's like and then i got home and he's
like and literally right when i stepped
into my door i had a phone call on my
phone right
so i answered and it was one of his
chiefs and they said you know you're not
allowed to talk about this to anybody
correct
he's like well you got to tell that to
the newspaper
place i already sent it to right so he
said for
years he couldn't get a job years and
years he he applied at big places
because he was super smart so he wasn't
just like applying like a mcdonald's or
some [ __ ] right
but they wouldn't they said once it got
to the part to hire him they would call
him and said
hey we actually we got a call from the
us government saying that we're not
allowed to hire you for this position
so that's what ended up leading him to
go into these things but
all right what i'm talking about with
the shooting right so he knows all the
[ __ ] and i've never seen him shoot but
he has all these [ __ ] guns right
so one time we go to go shoot out in the
desert
so he goes and it's the first time i'm
all excited go shoot with him and [ __ ]
and he's old so like his back was
already giving him problems and stuff so
he's going up and he's like all right um
he grabs a pistol we have all these
targets he goes okay
i'm like [ __ ] jason bourne
holy [ __ ] bro and then he grabs a
shotgun boom
bowling ball boom watermelon i'm like oh
my [ __ ] god and then he grabs a
sniper right
and he shoots at one he's like oh no
it's not sighted right starts messing
with it messing with it messing with it
[ __ ] starts hitting like a
300 [ __ ] meters away and [ __ ] damn
i'm like damn bro
that's scary dude he's like 73 yeah
they're just amazing
that's the thing about old people is you
never know who they are because they
look cute and old and fragile but that
dude literally could [ __ ] just stab
you in the neck
or probably killed 30 russians it's
crazy because he did so he's like
good at all that but he just has like
the worst luck like he has ms
you know he has stage three kidney
disease he's broken his back he used to
be a firefighter broke his back
when he was they were in a house that
was on fire he fell through laying on
his back broke his back
so it's just like with everything that's
led up to now like he's at a point where
he can't really even walk that long
but he like he wishes he can go shoot
and [ __ ] like that again but it was just
crazy to me to see
you know when someone tells you about
like all their history and [ __ ] you like
not that i didn't believe
them but it's great to see you all right
i'm like oh my [ __ ] god you're the
real deal son
he's the real deal bro i'm like that's
why you have these guns he's like oh i
used to love him he's all casual with
this [ __ ]
bro let me see this
you know the golf hat oh the samuel
jackson yeah just like golf hat yeah
his normal shirt this guy's a
multi-millionaire you would never know
it he wears
normal plain jeans that you would
probably get like at costco
right and just like a normal college
shirt with like just normal shoes
just walking around and he goes he's
like okay
i'm not missing everything this
motherfucker's hitting everything oh my
[ __ ]
are you shooting after me like hey i'm
straight man
oh my [ __ ] i'm like this i'm like
sideways yeah i can't hit for some
reason was the first time you ever shot
a gun
first time i ever shot a gun i actually
got really lucky
in the sense of hitting targets and it
was funny because my dad
questioned me about it so i was 17 i
think
well this is not your first time it's
like yeah i don't know what i'm doing
you know so we were like all into like
rap me is when i was rapping and [ __ ]
but
uh so my dad's like you want to go
shooting i'm like yeah i've never shot
right so like my dad's giving me the
whole course about
how to hold it and [ __ ] and we go there
and this is arizona
so there's a lot more guns out there
right i think one of the guys
was in the army had an ak-47 or
something i think it was that
might have been that or an ar-15 but i
feel like it was an ak-47 i don't fully
remember i don't know the difference but
all i know is whatever gun it was bro i
literally
like it was so but the trigger was so
light like you barely touched the
trigger and this [ __ ] shot like it was
kind of scary but
uh i think i was about 17 we went to uh
some desert in arizona and we had these
metal targets set up
and what's funny is you know a movie
zombieland
yeah yeah yeah it has i i don't know the
actors names
yeah all that all that type of stuff i'm
nervous i remember like i don't know why
that went through my head at that
point but there's a scene in the first
one he's like what you got to do is
take a big dead breath in and as you're
exhaling is when you shoot
and that was like where i got like my
breathing technique to shoot
and we had five targets and i hit every
single one of them
my very first time like pulling a
trigger on my gun and my dad looks at me
like
when the [ __ ] have you gone shooting
before i was like i haven't it's my
first time he's like have you been
taking my guns and going shooting or
what
i'm like no i'm like this is literally
my first time shooting damn
yeah bro but that was the first time you
scared the [ __ ] out of me like i know
how to get scary i know how to use it
now because like barton them
and taught me [ __ ] but i still remember
the first time i've ever was given a gun
was from a homie of mine
and you know like when somebody hands
you that [ __ ] it's like um
so write a passage almost right like hey
you gonna need this [ __ ]
that's the one they just gave to you
like it was illegal it was illegal as
[ __ ] yeah you know it gives me this
[ __ ] glock
right and i take it but i remember this
moment where i just took it and
i'm trying to act hard as [ __ ] i'm like
yeah thanks man new
you know holding york [ __ ] like a
sandwich again like yeah yeah yeah yeah
thanks
you know i don't know like yeah man i'm
gonna need this [ __ ] but i remember when
after i took it
was it like this the whole time you got
mayo yeah
yeah somebody put a spread on this real
quick i remember holding the gun and my
heart was racing right
and i just kind of like oh my god this
is a gun
this is actually the real thing it's
heavy it's real
that's the first thing that popped in my
head that was how heavy a gun is yeah
right
holy [ __ ] this is like my nerf gun when
i first got it i think the gun that i
shot the very first one was a
a nine millimeter it was like a compact
one this was a little smaller it's just
all like yeah but it was heavy i was
like holy [ __ ]
but what sucked is like after i hit
those shots i was like oh this is about
to be fun bro
and then like it's fun but like when you
have to shoot targets and you're missing
absolutely everything i'm kind of just
like all right
it's annoying it's cool to shoot but i
just don't see it's not that's like
guns to me it's like axe throwing like
once i did it for that one time yeah
i mean yeah over this it's cool for me
it's like once a year
yeah maybe or something like once in a
while but like how people like love to
go do it
every week it might be for some people
yeah i mean for me i guess like my dad
my dad liked guns he owned guns too i
first time i shot a gun i was like
six seven yeah my dad was like they took
me out to some canyon with a bunch of
random people and we were just shooting
at i don't know if it was legal we're
just shooting at a mountain
and uh he was like you see that target
that thing owes you money okay you hit
it right in
but yeah dude it was scary as [ __ ] too
like especially as a little kid i was
like
all right like boom and you feel that
[ __ ] that that little [ __ ] back and
[ __ ]
the scariest ones to me were like the
shotguns and the ar-15 because i know
like one that story that i was telling
you about him
that day we had a sawed-off shotgun and
we had an ar-15 do you have a sawed-off
and
a [ __ ] he had a sniper like well that
dude was a [ __ ]
and so those things don't you know we
had to set them up on tables and we put
them on our sam
and these sandbags yeah so like they
don't move and [ __ ] but don't
those mo when you shoot those things
it's boom
you're like [ __ ] bro like that [ __ ]
those shits are scary so
even every time before i'm gonna do it's
hard to like aim because my heart's
like don't mess up like don't like
[ __ ] shooting like that's why they
so you put like a fake bullet in there
so when you're shooting you don't
realize
that because even if you've been
shooting for a long time you kind of
like
anticipate the the kick right so
instinctually you just kind of jump into
the shot or you pull it a certain way
and your [ __ ] goes off so you put these
dummy rounds in there so you'll be
shooting
and on the dummy round you'll you'll do
the thing that you're doing you'll be
like oh [ __ ] i'm kicking it to the left
or i'm kicking it to the right
and you actually see what you're talking
about yeah even if you think you're like
hard or whatever you're still kind of
like
because it's [ __ ] crazy instinctually
like and you see some guys that are pros
like tim kennedy always puts videos of
him shooting
that [ __ ] shoots and like well
it'll be a dummy around and it doesn't
move at all like
you'll be like that dude's a straight up
assassin
you know i mean but i just like i always
crack up when i read uh people's
instagram posts and they're like i
practice shooting so i could protect my
family every day
where do you live [ __ ] do you live you
live with a suburb [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean like every day i'm ready it's on
my
like you're fine man like like the way
they would justify
how often they need to shoot a gun
because the whole world is like a war
ground is so stupid to me yeah yeah
i've lived in a very very bad
neighborhood i've never been shot at
once well that's not true
i've survived and i had a gun
yeah the sandwich one yeah
like making the noises because i held
the gun like this for two months and i
never had anything
when you know like what it can do like
it's just scary to me right scary bro
someone who's already scared of like
dying all the time
like when i have like a gun i'm like
[ __ ] bro like i don't want to touch this
and
i i had a school he's kind of a hard ass
so he he actually worked well he's
retired now semi retired he's a piece of
professor he teaches like law and [ __ ]
but he he uh was a a teacher in folsom
prison right folsom prison is like one
of the most high level security prisons
in all the united states right he's a
[ __ ] hard ass like he used to
wake us up in the morning by calling us
dumbasses
he was like wake up dumbasses it's like
the [ __ ] man
[ __ ] sick chill with that [ __ ] but
this dude lo and behold like there's
this whole backstory about him this i
told this before but
he was known in in like the elk grove
sacramento area because
uh as like the asian dude that would
just [ __ ] people up so he
he used to walk around and this is was
verified by
other people that we've met where he was
known as a dude that would [ __ ] people
up with nunchucks
yeah asian jokes at him so he would be
the [ __ ] that would beat him with the
most asian weapon of all
right that's so gangster they told the
story about him where
he wanted to like prove his worth to
everybody in the neighborhood
that you know he's not a little [ __ ] so
he joined the football team he was the
only like korean-american
asian kid on the football team so you
know he would [ __ ] [ __ ] up
so he went to a house party and somebody
called them like a ching chong or a
[ __ ] or some [ __ ]
and this dude told me this story is like
dude your uncle is so [ __ ] nuts
he had nunchucks he walked over and he
smashed that dude's trucks to
[ __ ] smithereens with nunchucks
took out the [ __ ] side view mirror
smashed all the [ __ ] windows
dented up the whole truck with it and
nobody would say [ __ ] to him wow
yeah dude that's a level in street
fighter
imagine being like so skilled with
nunchucks like that's how you beat up
people
yeah i feel
we were we we were trained how to use uh
a staff and also nunchucks
so crazy that's so cool also nunchucks
has the added effect of like so say
you're about to fight a dude
if he pulls out nunchucks there's that
extra moment of like are those [ __ ]
nunchucks
but you're already
so it has that extra psychological
effect the shitty thing about nunchucks
is is that if you suck at it that should
have beat your ass
absolutely yeah yeah so many times like
nut shotted myself
[ __ ] hit myself in the shin it's a
it's a very difficult weapon to use
yeah because most of it was for show
when we would do it right so we would do
like our poom says which is like
whatever [ __ ] and then we would do it
but then there was the application of
striking with it i guess that's what i
mean like
imagine like strike using it to actually
like that's what i'm saying like that's
your weapon of choice like oh i'm gonna
grab a gun let me go hey hold on let me
grab the truck right quick
i forgot what what it was and i'm sure
people can look this up but there was a
certain point
i think it was like in the 80s where
there was these weird weapons that were
outlawed it was like certain asian
weapons
so nunchucks are as illegal as guns are
oh really
yeah that's illegal yeah in certain
places here like
oh really yeah if you have nunchucks
somewhat
switchblades brass knuckles uh nunchucks
and like some other like [ __ ] asian
[ __ ] that's very odd but nunchucks were
one of them and it's just a stick with a
chain on it
yeah but if you walk around and you beat
somebody with that that's like
it's like severe [ __ ] people were
getting [ __ ] up with nunchucks back in
the day
and they're like bro
at the time's like look i know there's
an issue with nunchucks we're gonna go
ahead and ban them
just use
we were talking about the uh the [ __ ]
they were what rating that people are
raiding the capital right now or some
[ __ ]
i'm just a bill a cat over here
yeah little bill just i don't know
just depressed left saying because
there's a bunch of video obviously right
now and [ __ ] like that david said he
hadn't seen it till he came in
but there's a bunch of videos going on
right now there the video that me and
power talking about some lady got shot
in the neck
as they were like trying to break
through why by a security guard officer
yeah absolutely so
the overview trump right has been saying
that the election stolen
has been kind of riling up his base
being like it's [ __ ] we got to do
more fight harder blah blah blah so
today
basically a bunch of trumpers just
rushed capitol hill because they were
counting some electoral votes yeah it
was like the official
count like to solidify
like it's already yeah like the dude's
present you you guys lost yeah
you know but they they just stormed the
[ __ ] gates and they
got in they got into like the place
where they show on tv with the blue
floors and like the little
like the the circle room oh [ __ ] there
there's a [ __ ] like i told you
with the buffalo hat
and braveheart master standing there
like where the the speaker the house
whatever
he looks like you know do you know
nighthawk or i think it's nighthawk from
mortal kombat
i think it is no the the the dude with
the axes
is that who you're talking about yeah he
has like the red paint on his face yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the native american yeah that's
basically almost like what he was
dressed like
but with a buffalo buffalo hat on so
this guy looks like that dude looks
crazy as [ __ ] but whatever they storm
they're breaking windows
are you talking about the buffalo animal
yeah like a buffalo
animal like fur like you know like the
old like little [ __ ]
like like when [ __ ] dudes were
discovering america
yeah like
painted face like in the middle like
where the speakers speak like
yeah yeah just having people take it
yeah people are taking pictures
of that [ __ ] bro the evolution yeah yeah
like someone posted a
uh a picture he had broken into nancy
pele
pelepsi's office pilates
there's another guy that stole a piece
of her mail that like
happily is all taking a picture with it
like why are they tripping so much
so okay look these people are [ __ ]
idiots obviously you know
but in their eyes they they think that
they
believe that the election's stolen and
rigged
so they're like [ __ ] that like this is
the democratic process
we're like basically having a revolution
they just attacked
and so this is like their american civil
duty to go ahead and stop
biden from becoming president because
trump won and like you pointed out was
what's the end
like they got in and you see them
chanting like don't steal a vote but
it's like that
was not gonna get anything done like
they started out this plan the [ __ ]
guy with the [ __ ] buffalo
was like all right plan we're gonna
break in and then they're like so dumb
that they forgot to finish riding in
they're like oh let's go break in
all right what what else like what is
gonna i don't know
what is the outcome of this you guys are
all especially all those people that are
making themselves like
hella known for like at these spots you
guys are going to get arrested when all
this shit's done
absolutely these people stealing mail
from i mean the weird thing is
like because i mean i've only followed
it pretty loosely right but there are
people who are republicans
you know avid republicans in this open
space that don't agree with this they're
like
well even if there was a certain amount
of votes that weren't counted
it's not enough to overturn this right
it's very nominal like there's no proof
of this
yeah so it's just really dumb right and
this could be
for any type of presidential election
there was probably voter fraud to a very
small degree
exactly but it's not enough especially
how much biden went by so it didn't make
sense
you know well this is always this is the
problem all the time with this [ __ ] is
that there's
rational people like you're talking
about but most people
and then the loud [ __ ] on the
left and the right
cross causes crazy chaos and then we all
get sucked into it with like
there's this all this [ __ ] going on
and you feel like you have to pick sides
this is this and that but yeah
it's and what was the lady thinking just
storming the place like
what was the outcome that she was
expecting she
obviously i don't wish anybody to die
but it's like but it's like
like what do you kind of what do you
expect like you're breaking into this
thing right i don't know why she thought
[ __ ] security guards all dressed up
in like all black like men in black
style [ __ ] right you're trying to break
in towards these
congressmen and women that are doing
their [ __ ] they have to protect these
people
and it's not like like we were talking
about it's not like you're like knocking
on the door like hey let us come in so
we can make our voices heard
you guys are kicking in the doors you're
breaking the [ __ ] windows
so i mean what do you expect to happen
there's gonna be some sort of violence
if you rush cops you're probably gonna
get shot you know but the
the the other shitty thing that i've
been seeing too is on social media but
this is this is what sucks is that
like it's kind of true but it just gets
shifted into like
putting people against each other right
but i've been seeing a lot of memes
where it's like
oh like look at the white privilege look
at this yeah that's what i was gonna say
which is true
because like yeah if the protesters were
brown and black
like they probably would have shot them
all right away
and that's that's i think indisputable
but the thing is is like if you focus
just on that then you're buying into the
narrative that's pits everyone against
each other right now it's just like race
this
race when it should be about the
solution
is just finding common ground with
people yeah that aren't like you
and and that might be on the other side
of the aisle but they're actually you
have a lot of things in common that you
wouldn't think like a guy in la that's
middle class probably has a lot in
common with a guy
in minnesota that's middle class maybe
not ideologically
but like you want a happy family you
want to provide you want you know what i
mean like we basically want the same
[ __ ]
i feel like they killed that one white
lady just so they could just
you know put it in for the quote
you gotta kill one white [ __ ] one just
so they don't complain
that's basically what it is now it's
like it's turning into a race thing now
it is
right away because they're showing a
picture of that same spot
when the blm protests were going on and
they were dressed up like they were
about to go to the security guards were
like they're about to go to [ __ ] war
right and this one this was the crazy
video
as people are breaking in some of those
people breaking in they're taking
pictures with some
like a cop yeah you see that one yeah i
did taking a selfie and the cops all
posing with them and [ __ ]
probably because they agree with them
yeah exactly because it's their side
yeah you know it's just like cops are
pro-trump like that's like what it is
yeah but it's so crazy like
it it is kind of true in the sense of if
this was
uh a blm thing right and they broke into
there
like there would be bullets popping up
bullets popping off but right now
there like there was one video you might
have seen they're like walking in a
single file line like they're still
in the [ __ ] lights ropes they're like
just following it's like
they're just letting them do the [ __ ]
like the word and the rhetoric right so
when you see that
and then let's say it was conversely you
know blm
black lives matter or whatever and then
you see the title says
thugs degenerate yeah exactly right yeah
but then you see this you see
patriots and americans so it's like how
do you
yeah sure yeah and i think that's like
the part that causes like that huge
divide it's
you know it's media is personally
responsible for that too oh yeah how
they titled this
yeah it's like why are these people also
not thugs and degenerates absolutely
absolutely it's because it's easy i mean
a lot of people have been conditioned
socially to look at somebody's skin
color and say
well because they're black they're
mexican or whatever these people are
going to be thugs and degenerates
with murderers rapists or whatever right
but then you see somebody who wears a
buffalo hat
and i saw someone saying that that's not
as american
i saw someone saying that this should be
considered a terrorist attack
like because it's our our government our
national government and they're
attacking it they're breaking in
they're stealing stuff from this body
but that's what blm they were called the
people were calling them terrorists
yeah you know so it's like why is it not
on this side like they literally
attacked an american institution yeah
sure that is an act of terror isn't that
so i don't know man like it's it's just
so weird too and like i said
media does not help you know what sucks
is that the media
literally makes money off they're being
confident like as if there's conflict if
you think
[ __ ] the world's gonna end somebody's
gonna kick down my door you're watching
the news
right like that's what makes people
watch it's
fear it's it's the the fact that like
happy news doesn't get views right
like it's all just terror scared [ __ ]
you the other team's going to kill
you unless it's they're trying to steal
the election they're trying to take away
democracy like that's what gets people
invested and
that makes them money inevitably they
don't actually want to tell you the news
people that join the news aren't here
like hey i want to work at cnn because i
really want to tell people what's going
on
we have the same problem when it comes
to like a younger generation
that complains about media facets that
do this that kind of
um skew public perception but these kids
do the same thing on tick-tock
okay you literally do the same [ __ ] on
tick tock
every time you see something that
chronicle can be slightly racist
you go on this tirade about you know
what i mean like
this is you know i gotta say like i i do
that too but i'm doing in the guy's a
comedy
you know i mean like everybody's really
[ __ ] angry or offended depending on
what it is right
but it'll be like and i had to call some
people out on some of this i did the
last podcast where i was talking about
this guy who's just saying like
you know we're we as asian people like
our parents tell us that we're not
[ __ ] every day i'm like your parents not
mine
how dare you do what kind of [ __ ]
parents do you have yeah right like
you know and they they just like to say
things to get people riled up
and they're like oh my parents once
grounded me they are pieces of [ __ ] yeah
and it just goes into the snowball
effect of just stupidity yeah like
everybody does things just to be popular
just to be recognized
like cnn whatever type of [ __ ] news
faster or whatever they're getting a
paycheck off of this stuff
the sad thing about people who are on
these like social media stuff you're not
even getting a paycheck you just want
the attention yeah yeah like yeah yeah
it's cool i can't believe it like i said
that's what i was on instagram and like
part of me was i couldn't look away from
it but i like was feeling like kind of
like
dirty dirty and like grimy and just like
what the [ __ ] is going on like
like literally something really shitty
is happening and you're gonna
like i guess it's a normal human
reaction to just kind of like
the you just want to jump into the fight
and kind of start throwing punches
but it's like this is literally you're
playing right into the hands of the
people that want to keep people divided
like
that's straight up that's why i haven't
posted anything about it like i have
i've had a lot of friends post about it
but i know people that are like trump
supporters right
all that sort of stuff and then i have
friends that aren't so like if i were to
post it i know it's gonna start some
sort of conversation but
i'm just like i don't even want to get
involved in it the my first reaction
when i saw this [ __ ]
out my thing was just like okay when's
this when can this [ __ ] just be over
yeah yeah yeah i just wanted to also
shout out to the people that just kept
posting
videos of them like just eating food
yeah yeah
literally like the world is burning i
almost posted a story about it but i'm
just like you know what there's no point
because i don't want to talk about this
with
you know if someone has if someone's
with these people i don't want to talk
to them about it
right and like if someone wants to start
sending me all this [ __ ] about
why they agree with me i still don't
want to [ __ ] talk about it i just
want this [ __ ] to be over with
so i can just we have so we're dealing
with covid i don't want to deal with
well now
the audience it's because hopefully
people are getting smarter
to all this other [ __ ] we have to be
smart enough now to look at
the information that's given to us and
always question it first
now now this is just the reality like
for example in past in south pasadena
in south pasadena there was this thing
that was uh kind of popping off there
was this video of two cops
that put a bag over this uh young black
man's head and dragged him into a into a
police car
right right this was in south pacific
this was a south carolina couple right
so for me
you know my trigger thing is to always
be upset you know when i hear about the
stuff specifically because of what was
going on in the country at the time
and i looked at the video and i was like
something's off here
you know like what is this really about
and i saw this bag that was being put
over the head
and i saw that the bad didn't look like
just like a regular bag it looked like
something very specific
that's the place it was a spit bag so
what was this guy was doing
so this guy got arrested because he beat
the [ __ ] out of somebody i think it was
like a woman
or something like that and beat the [ __ ]
out of her so they were looking for this
guy and they would rescue him because he
[ __ ] assaulted
and get the [ __ ] out of somebody yeah
right and so they put the bag over his
head because he knew it was kobe so he
started spitting in the officers faces
yeah yeah so they put a spit bag on him
but the first thing that you read on
everything is like see what they're
doing the black men this is what i was
like
yes we still see it this is not that
case this guy beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody
and started spitting in these cops faces
and it's a spit guard so
you know they had to put out a statement
it's like hey we're doing our job
this guy was spitting in these officer's
face it's covered right now so we put a
spit bag over him he can breathe
perfectly fine
it's it's mesh in the front it just
prevents spin from coming out that's the
issue with
those videos and that's why obviously
it's terrible
that it happened but that's why it was
so good that someone started
recording that george floyd thing from
the beginning yeah right right because
then they put out people will put out
these videos like that
where it's literally the last couple
seconds of this guy getting the bag on
his head and thrown in his car
that's all we have so then it's oh he
got this but there's no video of it
before of him
you know beating up someone them
arresting him through that type of [ __ ]
right
um but yeah it's like that's the thing
it's like i always want to when i see
stuff or i hear stuff about that i was
like
i always want to see everything first
before i start just going off on it
right
the person who posted that and once
again you guys people know i'm like pro
blms but the
but the person who posted that only
posted because they wanted attention
yeah
they didn't do it they knew what
happened they knew that he beat up
somebody out in the street they knew
that he was spitting in these cops faces
but that person specifically knew that i
can get attention and people are going
to pat me on the back so i'm going to
record this
right so it's annoying like annoying
it's like we're already dealing with so
much [ __ ] we don't need your lies yeah
and that's where
you're faking your [ __ ] starts right
yeah you're spreading fake news
that's where it's always the end goal
what was the end goal of this like
people were going to find out and now
that you did this [ __ ] there's other
people who have real problems
they're going to be connected to your
[ __ ] of course yeah it's like the
[ __ ]
what is the wolf that cried sheep or
whatever my man educated
all right the sheep that cried boy
but it's like that right
[ __ ] it was too funny hey this is what
happens when you get kicked out of
school you know
but uh no but that's foreign
yeah but no but for real that's kind of
what it is right they keep [ __ ]
faking it that number and then at some
point no one's just
no one's going to believe you so when
[ __ ] actually starts to [ __ ] happen
she's about oh whatever it's just
another [ __ ] dumb story what would
happen that doing in high school if a
real new york game killed this whole
family yeah
it's just sad though it's sad to see all
this [ __ ] happening
to me the biggest thing is like we have
we have coveted right now
we have something that we need to really
worry about and then we got all this
other [ __ ] going on
it's like bro can we just focus on one
and then my boy dr dre just had a brand
like we have so much [ __ ] that we got to
worry about right now and then
dr dr dre's brain exploded huh those
shits are scary i had a client that that
happened to
and it was a very he almost died from it
uh
and you know right now it's a blood clot
in your head
and it was random i saw him the day
before the night before we trained
he was perfectly fine 100 we did our
whole workout
was perfectly fine i was supposed to see
him on that friday i saw him monday
wednesday friday
thursday night comes around i get a call
from his wife telling me what happened
and i
i didn't i'm dumb i don't know what the
[ __ ] a brain aneurysm is so i'm just
like oh [ __ ] okay you're like congrats
shout out to him i said what's up man
but like he's dying you [ __ ]
yeah but she tells me and i kind of just
get off to him like okay and then i had
to google it and i was like oh [ __ ] like
this is
this is like for real thing and he
almost died from it but
uh those shits are scary but dr dre is
good yeah he's good i mean he's got
money dude yeah yeah he's got that
money you fine that guy my client
uh i don't obviously he doesn't train
with we don't train anymore uh but he
can't really walk the same anymore
and it kind of like messed him up a
little bit oh yeah he had to
learn how to walk i'm scared about that
[ __ ] yeah that's what i'm trying to this
my new year's goals this year
is stretching and mobility baby nice my
[ __ ] knee finally feels good enough
like a jog now
nice yeah i started doing this uh this
knee mobility [ __ ] you know rehab i
finally started the rehab
yeah for that first time
rehab hurts dude yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ]
hurts i did not like it but now like i
gained
probably it's almost back to where it
was before still [ __ ] up but that
normal [ __ ] up that it was
yeah but you just got to make sure you
take it easy now just because it's good
don't go off 100
i'm still stretching and [ __ ] but i
stretch every day uh every day now so
i'm rolling out every day doing the
little rehab [ __ ]
man now i'm trying to make sure that i
stay here new year's resolution i've
been actually stretching too i mentioned
bro i couldn't touch my toes for [ __ ]
really and i was like [ __ ] that like i
gotta be able to touch my toes so i've
been stretching every day i started
meditating too i can kind of like put my
fingers on you meditating is the hardest
thing for me man it's
really hard like to empty your mind and
just not think
i don't think i'm good at it but i've
just been like i've just been
i've just been doing it get your [ __ ]
hand off your dick
you're not meditating you're jacking up
oh
this meditation feels boring it's
meditation
i don't i couldn't meditate bro like i
just can't like i can't
number one i can't stop moving so if i
have to sit in a spot and just sit there
and go
hey this [ __ ] i won't be able to do it
and just my mind i just
but that's the thing is well there's
different kinds so like obviously
the objective is to clear your like just
b right but that's like that takes i
feel like years to get to that point
right
or months whatever it takes time but i
think like what i've been doing is just
trying to just breathe and like count
my breasts to like 20. and like knowing
my shit's gonna
veer off like 100 but like just being
like okay my [ __ ] veered off come back
to the breath
and just keep going until i get to 20.
yeah that alone
that alone and it takes me like 10
minutes to just get to 20.
but that alone kind of helps me like
when i'm talking you know sometimes
you're talking to people and like you
just kind of like
zone out or you're like you're just not
there you're doing something you zone
out
i can like snap back and be like oh [ __ ]
i'm not there i should be here it like
helps me it does help me refocus
and it kind of makes me feel like good
in general yeah so like throughout their
estimate
can't underestimate a good ass breath
like you know
right you can't understand i don't know
what to say bro
[Applause]
[Applause]
bro the confidence in which you said
that like he just had you the ten
commandments
david you know what i'm talking about
like you're the dumbest [ __ ]
hey but let me let me give you some
clarity on this right yeah yeah yeah
you can't underestimate a good ass
breath right
that's what i mean because like i have
i have real bad anxiety right sometimes
to the point where it feels like i'm
always
like somebody's just always grabbing me
right like i can't like
like order like you know when you're in
a sauna and you just get to that point
where you're like ugh
like uncomfortable mm-hmm like that just
happens to me sometimes or like i just
feel so uncomfortable
i can't do it but then i have these
things where i just go
and then like everything calms down yeah
so that's what i meant like you can't
like the breathing technique right
you're counting your breath that's what
i mean
hey d you can't believe it
when i looked at you he had that face
like he was trying to understand what
the [ __ ] i didn't say that was funny
that's what i mean bro that [ __ ] like
it's common knowledge
that's not common knowledge bro
that's a shirt
uh the breakfast club where charlemagne
the god was uh interviewing this rapper
kevin gates
he was looked at kevin gates and kevin
gates was talking about how when he when
he [ __ ] his girl whatever he does
whatever right because you know when you
connect with somebody you do [ __ ] that
you probably wouldn't think that you do
then charlemagne the god looks at kevin
gates and he goes hey man he goes
that's why i eat ass instead of [ __ ]
because it's way cleaner and then
the room gets silent he goes whoa
wait charlemagne charlotte that's why i
eat ass
and everybody's like yeah bro
way too funny man after that well
everybody uh that wraps up this episode
of the genius brain podcast
my man said some ridiculous [ __ ] today
make sure you take your breaths
in and out baby yeah we don't want
drinking it
this color green will be slotted yeah
and
um that one whatever that one says i
don't know what that means
yeah i don't know what it is
it's italian the sheep called wolf bro
well you can find alex at lyft god on
all of his tags follow him on twitch
he's actually pretty good from what i
hear from people
yeah also because david released the
gaming podcast
i've had so thank you thank you number
one because i've had over like 200
new followers on it oh yeah yeah also
that's what's up
everybody where's david where's david
where's david where's david i gotta get
a new pc every day where's david where's
david
david where's david not so not even
i know we're trying to end this but even
real quick and i saw people comment on
the last one
which is true i think that you could do
twitch because
twitch isn't only for video games oh no
100 yeah like they do
yeah i mean david is busy i mean y'all
just saw enos
release the show on netflix so you can
find out all your
whenever i see him play video games
right like
i just be seeing people dying and i
don't know how that's when i get nervous
they're like hey kill shot kill i'm like
you killed him
i can't even see the people who died i
just see these numbers that pop i'm like
did you shoot that person
yeah yeah but no yeah it was cool uh
people want you so
you heard it here guys so everybody
keeps asking me he's gonna be me carson
all the time
oh i do i have it to where if you're new
to my stream you gotta accept that this
is a mature
stream shout out to the people who got
hella mad at me too they're like
david you don't understand about gaming
because you don't understand the art and
the interest
and i just wrote back all right i don't
care
i saw
and we will see you all next time every
thursdays and sundays baby peace peace
peace